thanksgiving is coming up
right and back in march we had no
idea most of us that we might still be
stuck in covet lockdowns and um
you know possible ends in sight but um
you know our children for instance have
not seen the inside of a classroom since
march
and who knows when that will change
um i posted this thread this was
actually before our first live stream
and i just i just want to read it um and
uh then invite everyone else to think
about what they're grateful for because
all of these things i am still grateful
for now
and maybe even more so uh
i created a hashtag gratitude in the
time of coronavirus
an invisible path from march 18th an
invisible pathogen races around the
planet
as we self-quarantine to slow its spread
many of us feel more isolated than we
could have imagined
and yet the global nature of the threat
proves that we are all in this together
i am most grateful for all the usual
things my husband and children
all of my family my friends my health
or health i am grateful to have a
comfortable bed
in a warm house in a beautiful place
i am grateful that clean water comes out
of my tap and i am grateful that it
warms when i ask that of it
i am grateful for the utilities that
keep the water flowing and the
appliances running and the device is
charged
i am grateful for the ability to cook
and for delicious nourishing food
i am grateful for good coffee and rich
cream and a handmade mug
i am grateful for the luxury of bespoke
drinks
i am grateful for humor and here i quote
tweet
someone who says work from home tips
have a routine
shower dress like normal keep a
dedicated workspace
fill a briefcase with sausages and
carried at all times
stick to usual work hours never let
raccoons trick you into twisting them
with a beefcase
they do not have your interests at heart
my next tweet in this thread is i am
grateful for the animals with whom i
share my life
even when they resemble raccoons working
at angle to get into my beef case
i am grateful for beauty i am grateful
for books
i am grateful for music i am grateful to
have a beautiful functional bicycle
built for me by my also beautiful
functional husband
i am grateful that taking this bicycle
out into the world will continue to be
possible in the coming weeks and months
i am grateful for soil and plants and
gardens and gardening
i'm grateful for spring i hope it comes
back
i am grateful for nature and here i
quote tweeted
myself from five days earlier on march
13th in which i said
engage in social distancing to help
flatten the curve but don't nature
distance
walk in the woods and parks and
mountains and on the coast keep your
distance from other people but not from
the sun and fresh air
get and keep your body moving don't put
your body in lockdown
correction i am grateful for most of
nature not mosquitoes mostly or leeches
or ticks or fleas or plasmodium malaria
and not coronaviruses still
this leaves an awful lot to be grateful
for and there is more
so much more what are you grateful for
that's hashtag gratitude in the time of
coronavirus
where we have thanksgiving in a few days
and we will be
having it as we always do with our boys
this time
only with our boys and and our animals
um
i am i am so grateful for this life that
we have together yeah
it is remarkable um so if i may
riff briefly on that beautiful sequence
uh i was charged with writing the
forward to
a famous photographer's book this week
and it caused me to think a lot i
am an amateur photographer but i was
looking at the amazing photographs in
this book
many things that you and i have never
seen in person
so beautifully captured and
i was moved to think about the fact
that this moment in time not
just the incredible accident of our
being present on this planet
and being creatures that are capable of
understanding what it means to be
present on this planet and what else
might be here but just the simple fact
that
modernity allows us to know about
the many wonders of the world in a way
that even a few hundred years ago
you couldn't have known what was here
even if you had reports of what was here
it was very difficult to separate fact
from fiction
and so you were left with kind of um
rumors of earth and that there is
something about
the technology which is often
frustrating and is obviously in some
sense driving us mad but that technology
is also giving us a great gift
which is the ability to know what's here
and for this brief moment that we are
present
cognizant on earth to have access to
some large fraction of the marvelous
things that are out there
i think is it's an amazing gift and we
just don't
we don't think of it because it feels
like okay well you're on earth it's a
big diverse place and it always has been
but no
even though it was most people never
knew and
and we can yeah we have access to much
more than we have
and hopefully we will have access again
to much of it in person
soon but but right now we have access a
tremendous amount
over over the airwaves
you